votre second débat le 15 novembre
prochain selon l'onu nous franchirons le
seuil de 8 milliards d'habitants d'êtres
humains au sur la terre alors que disent
les projections quelles sont les zones
du globe en plein boom démographique et
quelles sont celles al'inverse on
constate un recul on fait d'abord le
point avec marion livres
8 milliards d'êtres humains sur terre le
15 novembre prochain un chiffre
impressionnant et pourtant dans les
faits la croissance de la population
mondiale ralentit avec évidemment des
disparités selon les territoires si la
démographie se stabilisent en europe et
en amérique du nord elle est sur une
pente descendante en asie de l'est et du
sud est en revanche elle poursuit sa
hausse en afrique du nord et
subsaharienne en asie centrale du sud et
de l'ouest en 2023 l'inde dépassera la
chine en tant que pays le plus peuplé du
monde avec 1,4 milliard d'habitants
c'est aujourd'hui un petit nombre de
pays qui malheureusement à eux seuls
vous représentez plus de 50 % de
l'accroissement de la population cours
du prochain siècle
mais ce n'est pas comment dire ce n'est
pas un déterminisme ce n'est pas inscrit
dans les faits si ces pays se développe
si les femmes ou un meilleur statut est
bien l d'elle-même elles choisiront
d'avoir moins d'enfants autre élément
d'information le taux de fécondité
globale qui diminue il est passé de 5
enfants par femme en 1950 à 3 dans les
années 90 pour atteindre les 2,1 en 2050
pour deux tiers de la population
mondiale aujourd'hui le seuil de
renouvellement des générations n'est
plus assurée c'est à dire que nous
sommes plutôt une humanité vieillissante
qu'une humanité proliférante cette idée
que finalement fait l'humanité gagner
dans cette poupe descendants
c'est quelque chose d'absolument parce
que ça va à l'encontre de ce qu'on a dit
pendant deux siècles c'est à dire les
hommes ne ne cesse de remplir la terre
ils détruisent la terre et sont de plus
en plus nombreux ben en fait non en fait
aujourd'hui la question c'est combien on
va l'être à près de 1100 et on va être
de moins en moins nombreux et de plus en
plus vieux c'est super inquiétant 2100
qui devrait marquer l'apogée de la
population mondiale avec près de 11
milliards d'habitants avant de se
stabiliser
fille de décroître 8 milliards de
terriens on va faire le point sur cette
question ce soir en essayant de mesurer
quel peut être l'impact sur
l'alimentation est ce qu'on peut nourrir
tout le monde sur l'environnement est ce
qu'on peut être cohabiter tous ensemble
sans dégrader notre environnement et
puis on parlera aussi des migrations et
j'accueille pour en parler nos experts
ce soir françois gemenne bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes chercheur sur la gouvernance
du climat à l'émigration co auteur du
dernier rapport du giec et puis auteur
de géopolitique du climat chez armand
colin j'accueille également jean
françois riffaud bonsoir bonsoir
lecteurs général d'action contre la faim
et vos côtés laurent tout le monde vous
êtes démographe à l'ined institut
national d'études démographiques et puis
emilie zapolsky chroniqueuse politique
qui resté avec moi et qui restent avec
moi jusqu'à la fin de l'émission d'abord
un premier état des lieux avec voulant
tout le monde comment faut-il
interpréter ces chiffres de l'onu alors
la nation unis produisent tous les deux
ou trois ans des nouvelles projections
là il ya deux leçons qu'on peut retenir
la première c'est que on va passer à 8
milliards puis ensuite à 10 milliards
d'humains vers 2050 2060 donc ça c'est
tout à fait certain c'est un premier
effet est ensuite à partir de 2060 2080
et puis pour le 22ème siècle là il ya
beaucoup plus d'incertitudes mais on a
plutôt l'idée que la population des
humains va se stabiliser probablement
diminuer un peu on peut le voir se faire
donc voilà mais ça veut dire que c'est
c'est une humanité va décroître ensuite
françois gemenne c'est une bonne
nouvelle une mauvaise nouvelle
ça dépend de l'empreinte carbone de
chaque habitant en fait 6 la question
c'est celle du climat on en parlera tout
à l'heure la question c'est de voir
finalement quelle va être leur empreinte
carbone de chacun la question
fondamentale c'est la question de
l'habitabilité de la play c'est à dire
est-ce que d'ici 2100 l'ensemble des
régions du monde vont rester habitable
où est ce qu'on va avoir une sorte de
redistribution géographique de la
population à l'échelle de la planète et
la suivent encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes puisque ça va notamment
dépendre de ce qu'on va faire maintenant
pour réduire nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors il ya des
dynamiques démographiques qui sont très
différentes d'un continent à l'autre qui
pose des problèmes évidemment très
différent d'un continent à l'eau quand
il ya de pauvres sur ces 8 milliards on
le sait
jean françois riffaud moi je peux vous
dire combien de personnes mangent pas à
leur faim il y en a 1000 ya aujourd'hui
et pour répondre directement à votre
question il ne mangent pas à leur faim
parce qu'ils sont pauvres d'abord et
d'ailleurs je ma j'apprécie votre
approche parce que le sujet n'est pas
nécessairement quantitatif c'est à dire
ce n'est pas parce que fatalement nous
serions plus nombreux que mécaniquement
les gens seraient plus pauvres et moins
faim et que d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la
question de la faim dans le monde n'est
pas du tout corrélée à la question de la
quantité de personnes présentes tête on
peut ramener approche qualitative qui on
peut rappeler pour le grand public
quelles sont les grandes tendances sur
la faim dans le monde après les grandes
tendances elles vont plutôt dans l'autre
sens que le geste que vous venez faire
elles sont en train malheureusement
d'augmenter depuis longtemps déjà et
peut uniquement depuis alors qu'on en
parle beaucoup depuis en termes de
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
mais on est quasiment un milliard de
personnes qui ne mangent pas à leur faim
aujourd'hui dans le monde on était un
peu plus de 800 millions il ya une
dizaine d'années donc la tendance qui
s'était améliorée jusqu'à il ya dix ans
est en train de se dégrader parce que
les causes qui sont derrière ce
phénomène là se dégrade aussi et ses
causes là ce ne sont pas
la quantité de personnes vivant sur
terre ce sont les guerres c'est la
pauvreté ces changements qu'on avait
très bien est ce que cette population et
est en bonne santé en tout le monde
alors la population du monde à bord elle
est très hétérogène il ya des on a dit
il ya des gens qui mangent pas à leur
faim il ya des gens qui consomment
beaucoup ce qui va se passer dans les
dix ans dans les 50 prochaines années
c'est d'abord qu'il va y avoir plus
d'adultes et ensuite qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup plus de personnes âgées et ça
va être le changement majeur disons du
21e siècle ça va être l'explosion du
nombre de personnes âgées donc ça pose
des problèmes politiques et sociaux très
important parce que ça pose des
questions en termes de santé en termes
de système de retraite de solidarité
nationale donc on peut dire que
globalement la population du monde la
santé a fait des progrès très
considérable et sauf catastrophe majeure
on évoquait des problèmes qui pourrait
se passer mais quand même on a l'idée
qu'au moins âge égal disons les gens
vivent de plus en plus longtemps et de
mieux en mieux mais il va y avoir de
plus en plus de personnes âgées qui vont
nécessiter des soins particuliers et des
soins plus longtemps encore plus
puisqu'on parle de santé on va juste
faire un point sur les conséquences de
la pandémie de co vide dans le monde
avec vous
jourdain
l'écart a été l'impact miéville gère
l'évolution démographique sont unis il
ya eu plusieurs conséquences anodine ni
des conséquences à court moyen et long
termes pourquoi bien parce que le coc
vide agit sur plusieurs indicateurs
comme la fertilité la mortalité et les
migrations dans le détail le rapport de
l'onu nous dit que l'espérance de vie
général à la naissance a chuté elle
était de 72 8 ans en 2019 elle est
passée à 71 ans en 2021 une chute
principalement dues selon les experts de
l'onu à la pandémie de coronavirus si on
entre encore un peu plus dans le détail
et on se rend compte que cette espérance
de vie a été différemment impacté selon
les zones régionales en asie centrale et
en amérique latine par exemple
l'espérance de vie a chuté de presque
trois ans entre 2019 et 2021 dans le
même temps en australie en
nouvelle-zélande et bien elles progressé
d'un peu plus d'un an à la naissance une
progression due notamment à une
mortalité plus faible durant la pandémie
on rappelle que ces deux pays avaient
choisi la stratégie dite du zéro co vide
au premier cas détecté on ferme tout on
confine si on joue encore un peu plus on
se rend compte que dans certains pays
l'espérance de vie a même carrément
chuté oui en rose ou le vide en bolivie
au botswana au liban au mexique ainsi
qu'en russie l'espérance de vie a perdu
4 en quatre ans entre 2019 et 2021 en
revanche le dit l'onu difficile de
mesurer au niveau mondial mondiale les
effets du covin sur la fertilité dans
les pays à revenu faible et
intermédiaire le rapport nous dit que
bien la demande de contraception ainsi
que le nombre de grossesses et des
naissances non désirées sont restés
plutôt stables par contre dans les pays
à haut revenu national et bien les
différentes vagues de cloud vides sont
susceptibles d'avoir engendré des
variations sur le nombre de grossesses
et des naissances toujours selon l'onu
des variations mais seulement à la marge
enfin pour terminer mathieu le rapport
très très peu sur l'évolution des flux
migratoires
la raison on la comprend elle est simple
ce sont des flux qui ont été
littéralement stoppé pendant la pandémie
et il est maintenant difficile de
prévoir d'anticiper les évolutions à
venir de ton plus et bien qu'est la
pandémie n'est pas encore terminée merci
beaucoup steve alors on parlait de la
faim dans le monde et jouer je voudrais
qu'on y revienne on a les moyens de
nourrir tout le monde sait ce que vous
nous dites en fait jean françois riffaud
il se fait pas une question de quantité
c'est ce qu'on dit non non c'est pas une
question d'abord de quantité de
personnes mais ce n'est pas non plus une
quand une question de quantité de
nourriture produite aujourd'hui
30 % de ce qui est produit et qui
pourrait alimenter les gens aient gâché
n'arrive pas au consommateur donc ça
veut dire s'il fait si je prends le
sujet dans l'autre sens ça veut dire que
sur l'ensemble de ce qu'on produit on
arrive à nourrir 7 milliards de
personnes pascal 1 milliard qui ne mange
pas à sa faim avec uniquement 70% de ce
qu'on produit le reste et le reste est
gâché le reste est soit utilisé alors le
reste est en partie gâchée d'autres
d'autres partis ne sont pas utilisés
pour l'alimentation mais pour d'autres
activités notamment pour la production
d'énergie d'autres partis sont utilisés
pour l'alimentation des animaux et non
pas pour l'alimentation humaine mais
globalement le monde aujourd'hui dans
son organisation et le système de
production agricole mondiale même s'il
est loin d'être parfait on pourra y
revenir produits produire et
suffisamment pour que chacun trouve à
manger correctement et donc on voit bien
et on peut même faire l'hypothèse que ce
que l'on produit aujourd'hui pourrait
couvrir les besoins de 8 milliards et
demain de 10 milliards de personnes sauf
que on n'y arrive pas aujourd'hui et que
si on n'y arrive pas aujourd'hui c'est
que le système doit évoluer mais sait
aussi que les causes de la faim ne sont
pas liés uniquement à une approche
quantitative de quantité de nourriture
produite à tel endroit elles sont liées
à l'accès aux conditions d'accès des
populations à cette nourriture là est
derrière ce mot quelles sont les
conditions d'accès il y a
beaucoup de drames il ya les guerres il
y à changement climatique il y à la
pauvreté il y à l'inégalité de genre il
y a
l'absence d'accès aux soins l'absence
d'éducation et donc c'est un ensemble de
paramètres qui ceux qui se mobilisent
entre eux et qui d'ailleurs un sont
interfacés d'une certaine manière qui
contribue à cette situation là et donc
en d'autres termes et pour pas être trop
long a model constants c'est clair que
compte tenu de l'évolution du nombre de
personnes sur terre on ne pourra pas
régler le problème de la faim dans le
monde
donc la question c'est quand est ce que
l'on va décider de faire évoluer le
modèle alors est ce qu'il faut par
exemple changer carrément d'alimentation
françois gemenne parce qu'on le dit on
le lit le système agroalimentaire
responsable d'un tiers des émissions des
émissions et narbonne globalement oui si
on met tous ensemble et donc bien
entendu yaël nécessité à la fois de
revoir certains systèmes agricoles et
résister de revoir certains modes type
d'alimentation ce qu'on a dans notre
assiette assiettes dont très clairement
dans les pays industrialisés on a
généralement une alimentation trop
carnet et donc il va falloir diminuer la
quantité de viande et en particulier de
viande rouge mais aussi de produits
laitiers par exemple dans d'autres pays
la lan juste d'avoir une alimentation
qui soient davantage carnet d'avoir un
régime qui soit davantage protéines et
donc on en revient à une question d'
allocation des ressources au niveau
mondial et qui décide comment faire
autrement parce qu'un problème des
politiques au fond
qui décide quand on voit les échanges
financiers qui se font à l'échelle
mondiale on voit bien que si à une
rationalité elle est difficile à voir en
tout cas pour le bien-être de l'ensemble
de la population du monde donc mais un
comité de sécurité alimentaire
dial où il ya comité sécurité
alimentaire merci d'en parler parce que
c'est un c'était un des points qui nous
qui nous mobilise beaucoup chez action
contre la faim c'est que ce comité
sécurité alimentaire mondiale il a une
grande vertu c'est qu'il met autour de
la table ce qui potentiellement peuvent
décider mais alors pour l'instant non
parce qu'il est assez majoritairement
bail passé par les grands états les
états les plus influents c'est à dire
les plus riches le g7 notamment qu' on
l'a noté il ya encore trois semaines
lors de sa réunion n'a pas du tout
souhaitez activer donner le pouvoir à ce
comité de sécurité alimentaire mondiale
alors que pour revenir à votre question
qu'il met autour de la table les états
les nations unies les le secteur privé
les entreprises industrielles mais aussi
les les producteurs les petits
producteurs et la société civile et donc
c'est un des rares endroits c'est un des
rares cénacle internationale sous
l'égide des nations unies ou lens sommes
des personnes concernées sont là pour
construire les politiques
internationales la solution se recadrer
des prix
entre autres pas tous et c'est pas une
solution magique un cepal points mais
aujourd'hui par exemple j'aime beaucoup
cette approche a encore une fois parce
que on parle beaucoup des conséquences
qui seraient immédiats de la guerre en
ukraine sur la faim dans le monde et la
situation ce n'est pas l'absence de blé
aujourd'hui qui met les gens en
difficulté c'est leur mise et
on allait avoir on allait avoir
aujourd'hui les personnes qui sont en
difficulté dans le bassin méditerranéen
mais aussi en centrafrique mais aussi au
yémen mais aussi en somalie mais aussi
au sénégal pour prendre un pays un peu
plus
développer ce sont des personnes qui
sont faciles une augmentation de 40 à
50% des prix
la nourriture est là mais elle est plus
cher il ya un enjeu aussi de réforme des
marchés de denrées alimentaires qui sont
aujourd'hui devenus des marchés
largement spéculatifs c'est-à-dire que
l' équilibre du marché ne se produit
plus en fonction de l'équilibré entre
l'offre et la demande réelle mais en
fonction de phénomènes de spéculation et
notamment de spéculations sur l'état des
stocks pour lesquels on manque encore de
transparence 8 milliards de terriens on
a parlé de comment essaie de remplir
leurs assiettes on a vu que c'était plus
qu'une question de volonté
en tout cas de changement de paradigme
de que de quantité
j'aimerais qu'on parle maintenant du
logement est ce que tous ces gens là ont
un toit sur la tête dont on sait bien
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de loger une
milliards
de terreur
dans tout le monde alors là aussi c'est
un peu toujours les mêmes situations si
la population est très hétérogène tout
dépend de ce qu'on appelle un logement
et quelle qualité le logement quelle
sécurité pour le logement est ce que ce
sont des logements avec un accès à l'eau
avec un accès à une protection une
sécurité un accès à des infrastructures
qui permettent d'aller travailler de
donc aujourd'hui il ya des personnes qui
vivent dans des situations qui sont
considérés comme disons très
problématique vis-à-vis du logement mais
ils ont quand même un logement en toi
donc d'accord ils ont pas évidemment de
nos standards pour expliquer aux
téléspectateurs de confort ou de vie de
vie occidental ce qui évidemment normal
mais je dire normal parce que n'ont pas
les moyens évidemment dans les pays de
de les avoir mais vous dites qu'en gros
il ya peu de gens qui dorment
la belle étoile on ne parlait tout à
l'heure des changements liés au climat
il peut y avoir s'il ya des
bouleversements liés disons aux
problèmes climatiques et risque d'y
avoir des personnes qui vont être
déplacés alors à cause des guerres ou
des problèmes politiques mais il peut
aussi avoir des personnes qui vont être
obligés de quitter leur logement de se
déplacer et ça ça compte ça conduit à
des situations de très grandes
difficultés et fragilité et donc c'est
peut-être là dessus que les catastrophes
disons au sens de l'or que ce soit des
guerres ou bien des problèmes
climatiques peuvent avoir des
conséquences très importantes pour les
personnes qui vont perdre leurs
ressources et d'abord justement la
possibilité d'avoir un logement avec
encore une fois un accès au minimum
vital autour d'eux alors 8 milliards
d'humains ça pollue plus est ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on arrive à mesurer l'impact
environnemental de ce que ce sera contre
l'humanité comptera 10 milliards
d'habitants françois gemenne là encore
une fois ça va beaucoup dépendre
on revient l'approchent qualitative ça
va beaucoup dépendre de l'empreinte
carbone de chacun et très clairement
aujourd'hui dans le monde il ya
d'énormes inégalités d'empreinte carbone
aujourd'hui un citoyen européen émet à
peu près autant de gaz à effet de serre
qu'un citoyen chinois par contre la
chine et l'inde qui ont deux populations
pour le moment à peu près équivalente
non pas du tout les mêmes émissions de
gaz à effet de serre la chine émet
environ quatre fois plus de gaz à effet
de serre que lindon qui a pas de
corrélation directe entre la taille
d'une population et le niveau de gaz à
effet de serre l'afrique qui est
aujourd'hui le continent le continent
qui connaît la plus forte croissance
démographique est aussi le continent qui
connaît la plus faible croissance de ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
représente aujourd'hui à peu près 4 %
des émissions mondiales de gaz à effet
de serre donc il faut vraiment ordre le
cou à ce canard souvent les gens se
disent à la lame c'est la faute de la
démographie c'est un tabou renard jamais
de la démographie en fait on en parle
mais il n'y a pas de corrélation directe
entre la taille d'une population et le
niveau de ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre émis
politiques et des choix commerciaux
puisqu'on le voit bien on a parlé tout à
l'heure on reparle de souveraineté
alimentaire on reparle aussi de
négociations commerciales et comment on
fait on veut produire plus propre mais
on importe des produits qui sont
produits avec beaucoup plus de co2
j'avais parlé de lachine vous avez parlé
donc il ya aussi tous ces aspects là et
c'est une histoire de cohérence et on a
encore beaucoup de mal je reviens sur
l'échelle française à intégrer cette
planification écologique dont on a
entendu parler après la présidence mais
qu'on a bien du mal à faire passer parce
qu'on comprend pas très bien les
indicateurs comment on va évaluer tout
ça un peu à l'image de ce qu'a fait la
suède il faudrait mettre en place c'est
à dire évaluer chaque politiques
publiques et son impact sur le climat
sur le réchauffement climatique mais en
france on a encore du mal c'est des
choix très courageux on sait que ça va
coûter de l'argent parce que c'est
l'investissement aussi bien suivre et
c'est que c'est considérable dans
l'empreinte carbone de la france 40% des
émissions de la france sur ce qu'on
appelle des émissions importés
c'est-à-dire des émissions gaz à effet
de serre qui sont liées à des produits
fabriqués à l'étranger mais consommés en
france ça veut dire que si on devait
intégrer ces émissions à porter dans
l'endroit de carbone de la france eh
bien elle ferait un bond de 70% ce qui
permet de faire relativiser aussi
beaucoup le discours de ceux qui disent
en mai la france représente qu'un pour
cent des émissions bla bla bla
lorsque vous nous disiez tout à l'heure
en font que se sait plus on est riche
plus on pollue plus on est riche à
l'heure actuelle plus on est riche plus
on peut lui est à peu près plus de la
moitié des émissions mondiales de gaz à
effet de serre viennent des 10% les plus
riches de la planète dont nous faisons
tous partie sur ce plateau un soyons
clairs et c'est un instinct et c'est un
sujet dramatique parce que
lorsqu'on s'occupe lorsqu'on souhaite le
développement humain et qu'on s'occupe
des pays et des personnes qui sont dans
des pays sous développés on ne peut pas
considérer le développement humain sans
une augmentation
relative certes mais une augmentation de
la production de gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui les questions que nous
posons chez action contre la faim mais
comme dans d'autres grandes ong
internationales
c'est bien entendu de réduire notre
propre impact carbone et dont j'ai pris
un engagement pour notre ong de
réduction de 50 % de notre impact
carbone à l'horizon 2030 ce qui est un
engagement très fort parce que nous
aidons à peu près 15 millions de
personnes par an dans 50 pays
comment on continue comment entre autres
mais ça ce n'est qu'une partie des
choses et on n'a pas encore trouvé
toutes les solutions pour être très
honnête avec vous donc je ne fais pas le
malin si je peux me permettre là dessus
simplement cet engagement ce que je veux
ce sur quoi je veux insister c'est que
l'équation est particulièrement complexe
parce que notre mandat notre mission
c'est d'apporter une amélioration
d'abord de sauver des vies mais aussi
d'apporter une amélioration de la
qualité de vie des personnes qui vivent
dans les pays sous développés
et le mode après cette phrase là c'est
donc un peu plus de production de
carbone donc l'équation que nous avons
collectivement ça n'appartient pas
qu'aux ong à résoudre c'est comment
assurer une vie digne pour le plus grand
nombre d'entre nous et donc le
développement de ceux qui sont dans des
pays sous développés tout en minimisant
notre impact négatif sur la planète et
la question de l'augmentation du nombre
de la population n'est qu'un révélateur
des enjeux n'est pas un n'est pas un
problème en soi c'est un petit peu comme
le co vie d'une certaine manière est un
petit peu comme la crise climatique
cette question démographique
net 1 et n'est qu'un révélateur de plus
de notre nécessité de changer de faire
évoluer notre modèle pour que nous
puissions nous développer vivre
dignement mais que nous puissions tous
nous développer et vivre dignement et
c'est là qu'il ya vraiment un ange et de
justice climatique il faut aussi le dire
aux gens même si ça paraît un peu dur à
entendre si nous devons réduire nos
émissions c'est aussi pour que les gens
au sierra leone ou en république
centrafricaine puisse augmenter les
leurs parce que c'est une condition leur
développement c'est une forme de
péréquation mais pour pour produire plus
il faut plus de bras d'une certaine
façon dans tout le monde est ce que si
on a une population mondiale
vieillissante par une population active
qui se réduit alors bon d'abord ça a été
dit mais je crois que c'est important de
le rappeler les pays qui voient leur
population augmenter c'est pas les mêmes
pays que ceux qui aujourd'hui consomme
beaucoup de ressources donc il faut
vraiment considérer chaque continent
séparément et effectivement la priorité
c'est d'abord d'améliorer la situation
des gens qui sont des plus pauvres et
même à l'intérieur des pays riches ceux
qui consomment le plus ce sont aussi les
plus riches des pays riches c'est le cas
aussi des inégalités à l'intérieur de
chaque pays donc il faut bien
percevoir que l'évolution démographique
qui va y avoir de 8 à 10 milliards
d'humains elle nécessite des
aménagements mais c'est pas elle qui est
à l'origine des consommations des
dysfonctionnements qu'on va voir mais en
terme de population active on va avoir
de toute façon l'idée que pour sauver la
planète il faudrait que des humains
disparaissent c'est déjà une idée un peu
folle parce que la planète on s'en fiche
d'avoir des humains ou des insectes
c'est pas tellement la question c'est
plutôt la question de la régulation de
l'espèce humaine et de ce point de vue
là dans les pays développés si on veut
justement que les systèmes de retraite
et de santé continuent à fonctionner on
peut avoir une population qui diminue il
ya des pays en les dernières révisions
montrent que en chine la fécondité est
descendue à des niveaux très bas on est
en dessous de 20 2 enfants par femme
donc il peut y avoir des bouleversements
assez important il peut y avoir une
diminution de la population sans que ça
soit forcément un drame énorme parce que
il ya plus de personnes âgées qui
méritent des soins mais du coup il y
aura moins de d'enfants dont il faudra
s'occuper et les progrès de productivité
et font que a priori c'est pas forcément
un problème de voir la population du
monde diminue et on peut dire peut-être
qu'il faut éviter des chocs trop brutaux
et c'est quand même aussi quelque chose
d'important on voit bien dans les pays
développés il y en a il ya pas mal de
pays où il ya une inquiétude à cause
d'une fécondité pas se voir très basse
mais on peut dire que si la population
du monde se met à diminuer en raison de
2060 et 2100 ça sera pas un problème
pour la population le problème urgent
c'est ce qu'on disait c'est qu'il ya des
gens aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas de quoi
subsister il faut donner à ces à ces
personnes qui n'ont pas de quoi vivre
aujourd'hui de quoi vivre convenablement
on parlait du réchauffement climatique
bien sûr tout à l'heure qui est lié à
l'activité humaine mais aussi qu'est ce
qui lie à l'activité humaine c'est une
certaine passion la pollution des sols
des eaux fin des rivières des océans ça
on a une idée de l'impact que ça peut
avoir avec 10 milliards d'habitants sur
terre et c'est certain que aujourd'hui
si je prends par exemple la pollution
des océans avec la quantité de plastique
qui était mise dans les océans il est
certain que plus vous avez d'humains sur
terre plus il y adeux consommation et
donc plus il ya de déchets qui sont
produits mais là encore ça dépend
beaucoup des politiques qui sont mises
en place par certains pays certains pays
asiatiques par exemple on interdit les
sachets en plastique dans les
supermarchés le magasin et tout de suite
ça a eu un sur la quantité de déchets
plastiques qui était produit dans ce
pays donc vraiment il n'y a pas de
déterminisme ici c'est vraiment une
question de choix politique vous êtes
plutôt optimiste ou pc bien sûr ça n'est
pas optimiste par rapport à quoi je
pense que je suis carrément je conserve
mes choix politiques certaine forme
d'optimisme quant au fait qu'avec
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle génération je
pense plus consciente de ces enjeux et
surtout qui ne prendra pas la décennie
des années 60 un modèle de croissance
infinie comme une référence absolue je
pense que certaines choses seront en
train de changer la question c'est
est-ce qu'elles vont changer
suffisamment vite ça c'est vraiment la
grande inconnue alors cette nouvelle
génération va en parler avec emilie
zapolsky parce que l'inquiétude pour
l'avenir de la planète c'est même la
cause d'un phénomène le refus de donner
naissance à des enfants oui parce que
même si vous êtes optimistes y en a qui
le sont et rémois modérément mais quand
même un peu il y en a qui le sont un peu
moins et qui en effet refuse de faire
des enfants le phénomène il n'est pas
encore totalement quantifier l'institut
national d'études démographiques dit qu'
à 5% des personnes en france qui sont
dans ce cas c'est à dire de ne pas
souhaiter d'enfants parce que
réchauffement climatique parce que trop
de monde sur la planète et puis parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres risques comme
le terrorisme ou d'autres risquent même
de situation financière et économique
des chercheurs suédois alors sur le côté
bébé des chercheurs suédois et canadiens
ont essayé de quantifier de calculer en
fait l'empreinte carbone c'est drôle
quand même d'un bébé ils sont arrivés à
la conclusion que un bébé pèserait 58
tonnes de co2 par an alors ça c'est
énorme
le budget carbone pour garder le budget
carbone idéal pour tenir les objectifs
dr barry ces deux tonnes par personne
par an alors justement ils disent à
titre comparaison si on fait un régime
végétarien si on se passe de voyages en
avion et sciences passe de voyage en
voiture en économie seulement moins de
cinq tonnes par an donc en effet un bébé
c'est quand même assez énorme sur le
plan de l'empreinte carbone
c'est pas d'autre explication quand même
que la peur d'urgence batimat si
forcément sans faire la seule c'est des
questions de société il ya le féminisme
parce que les enfants c'est encore
toujours un peu une affaire de femmes
même si ça change désir de liberté la
montée de l'individualisme
la peur face à la situation financière
économique j'en parlais tout à l'heure
l'entrée difficile dans le monde du
travail et la peur tout simplement je
pense que beaucoup de gens pensent que
leurs enfants auront une vie qui sera
moins bonne que la leur et que ça c'est
quelque chose qui s'est complètement
renversées par rapport aux années 60 où
la logique de progrès faisait qu'on
était convaincu que nos enfants auraient
une vie meilleure que la nôtre et ça
trouve un écho dans la classe politique
mais pas tellement justement en matière
politique il ya peu d'attention qui est
accordée aux jeunes à leurs
préoccupations à chaque élection juste
un exemple le thème de l'écologie dans
la présidentielle c'est un des top 3 des
jeunes avec les inégalités sociales et
le pouvoir d'achat qui apparaît en
premier eh ben ça est arrivé c'est
arrivé très très tardivement quand même
dans le discours des politiques autre
exemple on se souvient rêver un hashtag
étudiants fantômes pendant la crise
bovine il est resté sont restées sans
réponse pendant de longs mois donc on
s'en occupe et pas du tout alors
peut-être que l'arrivée de députés jeune
génération à l'image du très bruyant
louis boyard qui vient de l afje de la
nul ça permettra peut-être de tirer un
peu la sonnette d'alarmé de développer
des politiques publiques qui prennent
davantage en compte les jeunes en tout
cas on peut espérer parce que c'est
l'avenir de la difficulté pour parler
très cyniquement les politiques savent
très bien que les jeunes ne vont guère
ne pas prendre les jeunes en
considération puisqu'il va cirque
vicieux et c'est
alors je vais quand même face à un point
quand même sur l'impact sur les flux
migratoires de cette démographie
grandissante on n'a jamais été si
nombreux et on n'a jamais autant bougé
au fond dans l'histoire de l'humanité
lors entremont alors il ya toujours eu
beaucoup de déplacements des humains
donc il ya plutôt eu avec les la
construction des états la construction
de frontières et cette idée un peu
étrange que on peut contrôler interdire
aux gens de rentrer ou interdire aux
gens de sortir du pays alors interdire
aux gens de sortir du pays c'est pas
tellement à la mode en ce moment les
pays qui interdisent à la population de
sortir sont pas vraiment très bien vu
mais ceux qui interdisent aux autres de
rentrer on peut aussi se poser la
question de la légitimité de cette
action est
aujourd'hui il ya un durcissement disons
des discours politiques mais qui n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec les mouvements
réels qu'on observe un les les gens qui
se déplacent en général ils se déplacent
à petite distance souvent parce qu'ils
sont forcés parce qu'ils ont des ils
sont contraints justement de quitter
leur logement et des personnes qui ont
de quoi se payer une migration
intercontinental c'est pas des gens qui
sont misérables c'est des gens qui ont
des moyens qui sont des richesses
potentielles pour les pays qui vont les
accueillir donc il ya une rationalité au
au déplacement des populations
éventuellement sur le son à grande
distance qui est complètement dissonante
par rapport aux politiques qui sont de
plus en plus durs dans de plus en plus
de pays sans aucune rationalité que
celle du bouc émissaire c'est la faute
de l'étranger et donc on va contrôler
les flux migratoires pour résoudre les
problèmes sociaux ce qui est
complètement enfin ce qui n'est pas du
tout fondées sur les faits et
inquiéterait interpellant aussi c'est de
voir que le taux de migration dans la
population mondiale convient de voir à
l'écran qu autour de 3% et demi le mans
reste remarquablement stable depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale dans
l'entre-deux-guerres vous aviez des taux
beaucoup plus important de l'ordre de 6
% 10 % même un certain moment vers les
années 30 et depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale il y a environ entre 3
et 4% de la population mondiale qui sont
des migrants internationaux et se
chiffrent le nombre de migrants augmente
par le fait de l'augmentation de la
population mondiale mais le taux de
migrants dans la population reste
remarquablement stable ces serpents ce
que vous venez de dire parce que ça tord
le coup aussi à une idée reçue en fait
ce sont pas les plus pour qui migrent
d'un continent à l'autre ce sont plus
généralement les plus les plus aisés on
l'entend il ya deux types de migration
il ya des migrations forcées donc qu'ils
sont vraiment dû à une contrainte de
survie disons et c'est là que sont
souvent à courte distance et elles sont
souvent très difficile pour les
personnes qui migrent et puis il ya des
migrations qui ont une qui sont liées à
une volonté d'améliorer sa situation et
là c'est des gens qui ont déjà des
ressources pour migrer et qui peuvent
être une ressource pour les pays où yvon
qui vont souvent se déplacer qu'ils vont
avoir des réseaux internationaux donc
les migrations elles aussi sont très
très hétérogène mais comme ça a été dit
disons depuis un siècle n'y a pas eu une
explosion des migrations et encore moins
des migrations intercontinental et
lorsque j'allais dans une explosion de
migration avec ce qu'on appelle des
réfugiés climatiques c'est aujourd'hui
un facteur important de migration et de
déplacement dans le monde si je peux
donner quelques chiffres en 2021 il ya
eu 23 7 millions personnes qui ont été
déplacées par des événements climatiques
extrêmes par des innovations par des
sécheresses par des incendies par des
ouragans
23,7 millions personnes c'est à peu près
deux fois plus que le nombre de
personnes qui ont été déplacées l'an
dernier par des guerres et par des
violences et donc c'est un chiffre qui
chaque année
s'établit entre 20 et 40 millions de
personnes à la grosse louche et à ce
chiffre il faut ajouter ceux et celles
qui sont dépassés par des impacts plus
le plus lent du changement climatique la
dégradation des sols la hausse du niveau
des mers là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à chiffrer notamment parce que
les facteurs de migrations se mêlent les
uns aux autres en afrique subsaharienne
vous avez 50 % des familles qui
dépendent de l'agriculture de
subsistance comme première source de
revenu c'est un type d'agriculture qui
est très vulnérable à toute variation de
la température de la pluviométrie donc
en gros toute variation climatique fait
que la moitié des familles perdent leur
source principale de revenus et donc
pour ces familles les motifs
environnementaux et économiques de
migration en fait c'est la même chose
parce que leurs revenus dépendent
intrinsèquement des conditions
environnementales la fin c'est
fatma la faim et la faim est un produit
de de ce phénomène comme comme d'autres
phénomènes et d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant de voir sur la question des
migrations notamment liée à la crise
climatique c'est que ce sont des
migrations de courtes distances comme
vous disiez et qui impacte
majoritairement des pays qui sont déjà
en situation de sous développement
avancé et qui touche majoritairement les
plus fragiles donc il faut bien se
représenter et qu'il s'agit de
populations rurales qui sont déjà les
plus fragiles parmi des communautés
beaucoup plus fragile que nous donc on
est vraiment sur une situation de
personnes qui n'ont plus rien au point
de devoir effectuer 100 km et essayer de
protéger leur cheptel de d'en perdre une
partie est de se retrouver
pour se protéger et pour survivre dans
un endroit nouveau ou une communauté
existaient déjà et où l'accès des
communautés hôtes aussi peut se
retrouver en difficulté donc la question
de l'émigration vu d'europe elle est
évidemment extrêmement autocentré mais
ce regard extrêmement déformant parce
qu'en termes de quantité mais aussi en
terme de gravité sur les populations la
question des migrations se passe d'abord
dans les pays du sahel dans les pays
d'afrique de l'est et dans les pays du
moyen-orient en particulier à une
échelle beaucoup plus importante et avec
des conséquences culturelles sécuritaire
mais aussi sanitaire pour les personnes
extrêmement grave vous rappelez de 3003
migrants sur quatre dans le monde
migrent à l'intérieur de leur propre
pays souvent sur des distances à ces
cours d'eau la migration internationale
l exception par rapport à la migration
interne et la migration intercontinental
et l'exception dans la migration
internationale ça va peut-être changer
aussi notre façon de concevoir
l'immigration vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure lors ans et on a souvent ce
ressenti de l'immigré qui nous pose
problème et voilà donc là on est face à
des mouvements qui n'ont on n'a pas le
même ressenti je pense à la gare en
ukraine on va accueillir ces réfugiés
al'inverse d'autres populations qu'on a
envie plutôt de repousser on va avoir
aussi des réfugiés vous l'avez dit
climatique des réfugiés pour la fin on
va voir comment on va les faire venir et
comment les intégrera dans la société
voir si les politiques seront intégrante
sur ces sujets là et autres sujets on en
pleine réduction du chômage en france
avec une pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui
est en train de naître on va avoir
besoin de main d'oeuvre étrangère
probablement c'est ce qui s'est passé au
moment du coc vide on s'est bien rendu
compte qu'on avait besoin de main
d'oeuvre qui venait du maroc et qui
arrivait pas et là on va avoir besoin de
cet appel d'air il va y avoir une
orientation politique un peu différente
de ce qu'on a entendu ou durci par
l'armée libération de tout le monde
reconnaît et vraiment ça fait consensus
politique manque une des premières
mesures en france pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
serait de lancer un plan massif de
rénovation thermique des logements qui
sont souvent des passoires énergétiques
en hiver des fours en était sale et le
climat les bénéfices sociaux bénéfices
en termes d'emploi simplement qui va
aller travailler dans le bâtiment et
dans le btp le secteur du btp vous dira
que ce sont beaucoup des travailleurs
étrangers un maçon sur trois en france
est d'origine étrangère et donc la
question c'est pour faire ce plan est ce
que nous sommes prêts à accepter
l'arrivée importante d'ouvriers
étrangers dans le bâtiment c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui bloquent cette
idée de plan de rénovation
est ce que le concept de frontière peut
être dépassé
non tout le monde faisait allusion à
l'heure où ces pays qui se refait un
repêchage en sortir son propre chef de
rentrer la force de la démographie c'est
qu'on est capable de prévoir à 50 ou 100
ans sans trop de difficultés et il ya
certains modèles qui essaye d'intégrer
des contraintes sociales climatiques
naturels politique et ses modèles
conduisent très souvent à des résultats
qui sont beaucoup plus éloigné de la
réalité
donc là je suis tout à fait désarmés
pour répondre à votre question est donc
ça n'est pas du tout une question liée à
la quantité des humains on voit bien on
a aussi l'idée que les gens iraient
d'endroits plein vers des endroits vide
mais en fait c'est plutôt contraire
l'immigration c'est plutôt des gens qui
sont dans des endroits vide qui vont des
dents dans des endroits où il ya déjà
plus d'humains donc on voit bien que
cette vision purement quantitatif que
vous évoquez sur la quantité alimentaire
c'est la même chose des humains ils se
regroupent là où il ya déjà des humains
et la nomme d'inventaire
de plus en plus grande des mégalopoles
de foot en plus grand avec des milliards
d'habitants oui alors il ya une
croissance des villes qui est très
importante c'est vrai dans tous les pays
du monde vous parliez de frontières on a
bien vu la la croissance de l'europe qui
se fait justement la fécondité est basse
mais l'europe croît en augmentant ses
frontières on se demandait jusqu'où
pouvait aller et puis voilà les six ans
concentrée elle va se concentrer dans
des villes de plus en plus mais la
notion de frontière sur le long terme
elle n'est pas forcément
disons elle ne permet en rien
d'améliorer ce qu'on va comprendre de
l'évolution des hommes d'ici 20 ou 30 et
40 et puis ici je peux me permettre elle
ne résiste pas à l'humanité la question
de frontières c'est à dire que le sujet
c'est patent de la remettre en cause
c'est de se dire à quel moment faut-il
pouvoir la dépasser cette notion là
encore une fois ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut la faire disparaître mais à quel
moment faut-il être capable de la
dépasser et nous les humanités on est
parmi les moins bien placés pour le
savoir parce que notre mandat
d'humanitaires et le droit international
iter nous y autorise mêmes nous le
demande c'est de ne pas regarder ni
l'origine des personnes ni leurs choix
de vie mais de ne pas regarder non plus
la nature des territoires sur lesquels
nous sommes et que donc de ce point de
vue là je trouve que si on peut engager
une réflexion où on met face à face la
notion de frontières avec ce que ça
implique en termes politiques en termes
culturels en termes historiques en terme
économique mais aussi en termes d'
humanité par rapport aux besoins de
l'humanité souffrante et bien on peut
espérer que de ce point de vue là de ce
point de vue là il faut pouvoir dépasser
ce concept là parce qu'il faut pouvoir
accueillir il faut pouvoir aussi se
porter au près et surtout permettre à
ceux qui souffrent de se porter auprès
de ceux qui les secours ce qui est
frappant c'est de penser qu'il ya un
siècle vers 1920 1921 la france convoqué
à paris de grands sommets internationaux
pour discuter de l'ouverture des
frontières à l'époque la migration était
vu comme quelque chose à encourager les
frontières était vue comme un obstacle
qui risquait de ralentir les migrations
les déplacements et donc ont proposé
d'ouvrir carrément les frontières
finalement l'a pas fait c'est l'occasion
de ces conférences qu'on a décidé
d'harmoniser le format des passeports
mais ça veut dire que cette idée qui
paraît complètement aujourd'hui
utopique complètement utopique il y à
100 ans était défendue par la france qui
sait ce que deviendront les frontières
d'ici 2100 20 mai parce que ça peut se
jouer que sous une forme de régulation
mondiale là encore c'est un peu comme le
comité tout à l'heure le comité
c'est une utopie d'imaginer que les pays
se mettent d'accord vous qu'il ait
côtoyé les étals et
oui je mesure les moyens encore j'ai la
meuse oui oui oui parce qu'il ya pas de
fatalité c'est comme pour la fin il n'y
a pas de fatalité la fin c'est pas une
main invisible méchante dramatique qui
causeraient ça de manière
incontrôlable non ce n'est pas vrai donc
tant que je serai convaincu que ce n'est
pas une fatalité et que la misère
humaine n'est pas une fatalité je serai
un petit peu optimiste en tout cas je me
battrai là dessus et je pense même qu'on
arrive à un moment où ce que vous nommez
d'utopie jeu je
n'accepte en effet
et peut-être de moins en moins une
utopie parce que les appelle les rappels
à l'ordre le coc vide la crise
climatique
qui produit ses effets que nous mesurons
et que nous apprécions tous les jours
les guerres le
dérèglement de nos systèmes collectifs
sont en train aujourd'hui de nous
montrer que ici ou là bas au nord ou au
sud nous sommes confrontés aux mêmes
enjeux et je voudrais juste ajouter une
idée c'est qu'il y a
une initiative qui existe depuis
longtemps déjà que ça paie les objectifs
de développement durable les dix sept
objectifs veulent parler rapportés par
les nations unies qui ne sont rien
d'autre que l'expression de la
souveraineté des états les nations unies
les 192 états qui se sont mis ensemble
qu'ils ont dit on va essayer de faire
quelque chose en commun en partageant un
peu de souveraineté
cette ses objectifs de développement
durable si on les regarde attentivement
on se dit qu'on pourrait en faire une
grille de lecture pour tout gouvernement
puisque nous sommes sur une chaîne qui
est liée à la gestion politique et bien
il serait peut-être bon de réfléchir à
la gouvernement d'un pays la france où
un autre à travers cette grille de
lecture qui finalement
traduit et pourrait en tout cas guider
les réflexions d'un ministère des
finances d'un ministère de la
transformation écologique mais aussi
d'un ministère de l'éducation est ce que
la ministre normandeau et cela pourrait
être une grille de lecture commune et je
constate aujourd'hui si je comprends
bien que en france s'est obstinément
durable sont plutôt rattaché au
ministère la transformation écologique
et au ministère des affaires étrangères
ça serait bien que ceux rattachés à
matignon eh bien merci beaucoup ce sera
le mot de la fin on a bien compris au
cours de ce débat que les questions
n'étaient pas seulement de démographique
mais qu'elle était surtout politiques
aux traîtres les choix étaient
politiques c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à tous d'y avoir
participé